like I say you can have practically
anything you want in life but you can't
have everything you want in life so that
means you have to prioritize what are
the things you're going after that has
to do with the earlier part of you know
know what you're going after that
matches your nature to the the path okay
be clear do you know that as afterite or
maybe you're discovering it but make
sure you discover it then when you get
there you will encounter your obstacles
and problems they will surface so you
pause and you say okay that's a problem
it's an obstacle and you work with
somebody who's got a personality who
would and and you appreciate their work
either to help maybe they do some of
those things for you that need to be
done or maybe they help keep you on
track or something then you will have a
design that will work and then if you
take that design so many people form
designs but they don't follow through
and don't do it so step number five is
do it okay do it and then you do this on
an ongoing basis that's why I have these
Loops you know uh you know all the books
and everything have these Loops because
that's what evolution is like you you
learn something and then it starts to
fail and you start to fail and and then
you reflect and then you learn something
and you do it differently and then you
go up to a new higher level